un petit bip et le tour est joué
dans ce bureau de vote de nevers pas de
bulletin d' enveloppe est dur nos
classiques
les électeurs doivent simplement appuyé
sur le nom de leur candidat pour voter
et c'est comme ça depuis dix ans on a
l'habitude ici ça fait plusieurs années
que de cette façon là c'est très bien
très pratique très rapide ça évite de
trier tous les papiers donc c'est très
bien mon électronique
voilà c'est ça fait longtemps comme les
fussistes 1er laissé tomber à nevers
tous les bureaux de vote en sont équipés
choisir contrôler et valider un
processus a priori simple mais pas pour
tout le monde
non mais c'est vous qui vous prennent ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas validés je le vois
voilà si certains ont eu un peu de mal
d'autres sont déjà nostalgique ça perd
un peu le charme de l'ancien avec avec
les petits papili l'enveloppent cacher
tout etc
c'est un peu dommage mais c'est pratique
le reste de la démarche reste
traditionnelle présentation des cartes
d'électeurs et d'identité émargement le
gain de temps est donc en réalité minime
pour les lecteurs mais il l'est
davantage pour le décompte final
je suis capable de vous donner
exactement un nombre de votants cette
heure-ci liliana 581,2 alors autrement
une fois pas attendre le soir et c'est
surtout le gain de temps et surtout le
dépouillement après puisqu'en dix
minutes normalement on a des résultats
'l'annonce publics des résultats de
versoix aura lieu au palais ducal à
19h30
quelques minutes avant les premières
estimations nationales